okay carlos have you heard of fansley
yes i have actually well it's a special
shout out to our favorite adult friendly
platform fans it's the best platform to
connect one-on-one with your favorite
creators in new and more intimate ways
than ever before
what are you waiting for check out
fansley.com and that's
fansleyfansly.com for exclusive content
from your favorite creators
chat unlock exclusive content watch live
streams and connect your twitter or
twitch to see if creators you already
engage with are on fansly today and now
a word from our sponsor betterhelp
betterhelp is easy and affordable online
therapy when you want to be a better
problem solver therapy can get you out
there visit betterhelp.com
trash tuesday today to get 10 off your
first month that's betterhelp.com
tuesday betterhelp.com
trash tuesday thank you to our sponsor
native
their plastic free deodorant is aluminum
and paraben free kills odor-causing
bacteria and has 24-hour odor protection
to keep you feeling and smelling fresh
baby go to nativedio.com
tuesday or use promo code tuesday at
checkout and get 20 off your first order
that's native nativedeo.com
tuesday or use promo code tuesday at
checkout for 20 off your first order
this coming weekend the 9th and 10th i
will be
in pittsburgh pennsylvania at the improv
i will be at la jolla comedy store 9 16
through 17. i will then be a tempe
improv in arizona september 23rd through
24th and then one night only at the
casino
i'll be at the caluso california casino
one night on the 30th it's gonna be the
best check out annie letterman.com shows
for all those dates
also uh my spotify live show is
um was postponed yesterday because it
was
labor day so it will be tonight at 5 00
pm pst and 8 pm eastern so you can check
that out go to my socials it'll be up
there on my instagram austin texas
september 16th and 17th i don't have a
place to sleep yet so i'm either
sleeping on an ex-boyfriend's couch or
at a fan's place preferably a female who
has a really nice guest bedroom
so i will see you guys september 16th
and 17th get tickets at esther on ice
dot com i can't wait
[Music]
okay folks
from
the hit podcast
you changed the names i've
just saying
just saying we have adjusted
[ __ ] martindale folks beautiful
the best hair and comedy thank you
he was supposed to come we weren't sure
we were it was undecided whether there
was going to be a theme well i i did get
half a notice that perhaps you were
going to come in um selling sunset god
but it would have been insane if it was
just you but now
but i failed at the outfit but have you
watched selling no okay selling the oc
oh it's selling the oc so who were you
gonna come dressed as you were just
gonna be in a suit you were just gonna
come looking like hot no it was gonna be
it was gonna be a a mess of things
because this is them dressed up
like this is them doing like oh this is
the the cover shot like kind of like the
housewives theme right he's in it too
they're selling the oasis the little
guys
they're all little which one
the bald guy oh that's the openheim guy
yeah that's open so it's their like it's
their oc spinoff okay oh we could have
all been wearing royal blue yeah but
also that they their cocktail attire
like
they're i almost wore that outfit i
literally almost wore one of those like
oh that's kayla
uh kayla and alex uh won
is this like there's three alex this is
the new one right yeah it just came out
okay i'm gonna burn through it in like a
day and a half i'll watch it it's so
good i'm stuck on a indian matchmaker
right now oh yeah
is it good um so far not as good as the
first season oh really yeah but i i like
to see
messy brown folks messy
it makes me feel so much better about my
life because i always see just messy
white people
on reality tv so when i see messi like
like uh that is a bling empire
empire is great
finally asians being represented in the
correct way disastrous christine oh
she's so um
i went to the jersey shore and i went
and i asked a guy
just to do some preliminary research i
asked a henna guy if he would do a
tattoo on my head of a dick and he would
i didn't i wasn't ready for it but we
like one of our first episodes we had a
pog off remember pogs
yeah
yeah
which by the way it's so you're like
a-okay
why do you make everything a butthole
justin oh um
house of hoe i remember house of hoe
which is annie letterman's news special
it's just my vagina
the house of the ho it's rich asians in
um houston oh yes
this is their bling empire this is hbo
max is playing empires
mickey glazer just randomly hosting it
she just comes out why not
what's interesting about asians
is that they never want to be
represented as anything but like
extremely like filthy [ __ ] rich
so it's like what's it honey boo boo
like duck dynasty you have all of this
like kind of like trash like
whities
and i love it and i love it
over their [ __ ] dead rich bodies
would they ever be represented as
anything but extremely wealthy and it's
kind of a bummer but i'm glad they're
equally [ __ ] disastrous yeah i think
you know what's funny is that the um
uh
and i was in vegas recently and they had
a uh
what's the they had a crazy rich asians
slot machine oh no it's a great one
that's really fun except it wasn't
giving me as much i'm telling you that's
so funny you brought it up i'm gonna
subscribe the crazy restoration slot
machine i have such good
times on slots but um the crazy rich
asians is a good one and i was just in
atlantic city with my
soon-to-be in-laws
what did you get engaged no but he asked
my parents for my hand in marriage oh
and then they reported it back to you
yeah they told i know my mom was like he
just asked us a question like is
anything a secret
no
he also we got a fight because he goes
we're you know how we're supposed to go
to mexico you know that got canceled yes
they got cancelled but um todd was like
maybe you're going to get a surprise in
mexico and i was like why would you tell
me
what diarrhea like there could be so
many things
to me
i'm like what don't tell me when you're
going to do it i was like i would not
have had any clue yeah i'm going to sew
a bag of fentanyl in your stomach hey
hey mexico
i mean i'm gonna put the ring around the
condom that's holding all the heroin i
actually think you'd make a great mule
thank you so much my [ __ ] so big no
because you're almost so overt that like
there is no like and like that cannot be
like the loudest girl here cannot be the
mule yeah they'll be like her tracks are
showing she's being crazy she's telling
her to pat down her [ __ ] that can't be
any drugs you're like a bad mule wait
did i tell you about my lesbian
experience at tsa
no it went off
i you do you look at the screen right
when you go through the you do the thing
and then turn like the little screen
which is hot i want to know what the hot
spots are my hot spot was my puss i was
wearing shorts
and it
um
this is a weird diagnosis but it was
like you know it's like the red with
like a yellow oh you had yellow and it
was right here and i went oh no and then
the woman was like oh no like we both
were like oh no and she's like i'm gonna
have to
finger you she's like i'm gonna have to
pat you down she went and she was like
very butch she was like do you want she
and she asked me if i was trans she goes
no offense she goes are you trans i want
to be like are you [ __ ] like what the
hell and then
so then she like asked her that she
asked me if i was trans but i'm like
what did you do you still got it you
still got it
i know it's like i wish it was the first
time this is the first official was the
first time someone had a badge of sorts
asking me this
alternately i know that the hot spots
when they have to pat me down is my wet
hair like the tips when it hasn't dried
so they were like when hair is your
[ __ ] wet bush i was leaving texas it
was a little humid well that'll do it
yeah
and so she how did she go about that she
i she swiped my ass too where i'm like
[ __ ] it did not show up on my ass
she was like do you want to go to a
private room and i was like do you like
the whole thing like oh she did
my boyfriend was laughing so hard it was
so i was like crying laughing did you
have to take your pants off and all that
no she just like gripped around gripped
around
she gripped around she swiped me she
credit card swiped me she followed me on
instagram afterwards she was so upset
she was like she didn't want to do it
none of us were like but i was like
you're faking you're not a little
excited i'm pretty cute i had my
extensions
i mean how tight were your coochie
cutters they were really at my post like
it must have just been they were so like
crumpled up
annie oh
like like an old burrito foil
why did you have to say burrito i don't
know i just crumpled that just came to
mind
he's like when i look at your taco i
think more of a burrito yeah or like or
would you think of like like a like a
like a corner full of like daddy long
legs
yeah it's like yeah it's like daddy long
legs on their back
their bottoms like a nice summer eve
porch no douche intended
uh do you douche i have never douched in
my life no i don't do you
prep
i had anal sex one time okay same yeah
and i had to ask a lot of questions of
people and
i did even though people told me i
didn't have to i did get like a
uh enema thing you get the breathing
prep yeah i just really didn't want to
shed on this guy's deck like i was what
kind of enema did you use i got one of
the fleet ones yeah but then i was
staying at my friends medical ones that
i have to use on people
yeah i mean
we've been friends you would have been
involved you have been spreading esther
would've been holding the cheese we'd
been using the ass tape oh yeah esther
would totally hold it down esther really
would honestly it's kind of sick
she really esther would be the enema
yeah
esther's entire body is inside me i'm
pooping around right now elbows deep in
five seconds the guy who was like who
his house i was the friend whose house i
was staying at there was only like one
key to get in so he had a buzz to get in
so i was like gave myself the thing and
was like in the tub you know like in the
bathroom area and i had to like
cup my [ __ ] and like run and let him
in in the middle of it wow how long
before it um it was like mid square it
was pretty bad it was like yeah
i was laying you know i was like face
down ass up yeah in the tub
and uh and then i was cupping and
running and wait face down ass up you
know it doesn't have to be that way
no i
i wasn't doing it well
i didn't do it right i mean you have to
it
practice makes perfect you know
it sounds like a new broadway musical as
well the ladies who douche and the dudes
she loved the ladies for lunch you'll
love the ladies who do the house of
douche
house of the duchenne yeah i went viral
last week i don't know if you saw that
what did you do
i was [ __ ] completely offline so sick
i'm i disrupted the zodiac um
uh killer
not the killer the actual zodiac like
the astrology of everything because i
had
heather morris from glee on my podcast
and she said that when she was a backup
dancer for beyonce
there was a um dancer
uh a hearsay dancer yeah that
there was a jennifer lopez audition
and the
jennifer lopez showed up like you know
they've been there all day she shows up
like 15 minutes
like before it's supposed to be over
she's like thanks so much for being here
all day and working your asses off but
are there any virgos in the room and the
burgers raised their hands she's like
you can go home now and
the internet went
like it was crazy so funny every damn
news outlet i was just getting like
notified like
like vanity fair
did i ask you did they call you no no
one called me they were just like but i
you know got a lot of people like
talking about my podcast which was great
but it was like
every news article
trickled down it was great seeing like
it on like local news because people
were like jennifer lopez hates virgos
coming up after the break it was just
like what is it
i think whitney is bobby his birthday's
coming up but did we know that ben
affleck speaks fluent spanish he does
yes
i did not know this he isn't that he's
after all
i have no clue fluently too yeah let's
hear how did the earth smell like bad
breath
[Laughter]
i don't like it
these are all basic spanish things
though he said i have spanish friends i
eat beans it's like they're covering
like but
the the way his accent and the way his
like his it's it's pretty did you see
that
though
it's like wait a minute i know it's like
oh nothing was better than that that was
so beautiful i love it i'm not talking
about it
how do you say
cucumber
yeah it's just so weird to lie about
something
yeah
so why she really is like such a joy to
read about though anywhere yeah
yeah and her like ninth child i think
she's pregnant with her seventh i know
she and nick cannon are in a
race that's too much mckenna has another
one oh i know oh i know i know viveka a
fox said enough that's so funny she said
stop it you're making us look bad
don't claim america
and today's podcast is brought to you by
fansly an innovative adult-friendly
platform think tik-tok but for spicy
content and exclusive access to your
face say your faves baby you can follow
subscribe message creators to chat
one-on-one unlock pay-per-view
zones
you definitely won't see anywhere else
and discover new
favorites on fans leaf on the fans leave
for you you got this annie
where new creators are suggested based
on the ones you already love and engage
with so
if you see me
you'll see
lady gaga fancy even protects your
content with free copyright takedowns
and chargeback protection and welcomes
creators of all fan base sizes whether
you're already established or just
beginning you can post safe for work
picks by day spice it up at night or
both with tons of optional features like
sub tiers paid messaging and more
that's where you're going to see my my
feet and great
that would do well that would do so well
i know but it's like the bit is not
about money it's about like how long can
i guard my feet yeah well you know what
with fansly annie you are in charge
you're right i'm in charge
so feet and greet it is feet and great
is but the tier is one million dollars
you would make a lot on fansly actually
because the average creator with just a
thousand followers on social media which
you have way more than earns 500 a month
now you actually don't have that much
more than that but you actually would
make money too i have six thousand
followers
carlos we should fans leave you up what
are you waiting for carlos guys what are
you waiting for sign up today at
fansley.com that's
fansleyfansly.com for exclusive content
from your favorite creators and now a
word from our sponsor betterhelp
guys look
obviously there's
ups and downs there's peaks and valleys
in this episode even i mean when do i
not need help
i don't know she's crying for help at
all times anxiety spread eagle screaming
for help this is me screaming for help i
am anxiety ridden i get depressed a lot
annie is dying from terminal something i
have been sick for so long
guys i've been sick for so long that
it's affected me mentally i mean she is
dealing with some type of chronic
um medical ailment an ailment whatever
it is whatever it is we i've lost
friends i've lost family i've lost work
we all need help at some point and
that's why we turn to better health
better help is affordable online therapy
you can be matched with a um therapist
in under 48 hours um
what i love about it it has this journal
feature she loves the journal feature
she's a poet guys i love you she writes
poetry so she likes to write her
feelings we like to read it honestly but
you're not gonna be able to read her
journal because this is
confidential better help and when i'm
feeling this way it can be really tough
for my brain to stay on problem solving
for us too for us too yeah when i'm
faced with a challenge in life but when
you learn to find your own solutions
there's really no better feeling and
that's where better help comes in a
therapist can help you become a better
problem solver making it easier to
accomplish your goals no matter how big
or how small look don't be the guy
without therapy don't be the person that
doesn't have therapy and therapy is so
annoying it's like sometimes it feels
like the universe is set up to make it
hard to get therapy like it's like you
know
you got a call try to figure out the
insurance all the stuff you got to find
parking and other stuff better help is
just a one-stop shop you can just go
online you don't have to go anywhere it
makes it easy for you to just get better
don't be the people that don't get
better just get better you're not going
on dates if you're not in therapy that's
like question one on dating apps are you
on in there yeah this is a different
this is a different time baby okay it's
not cute to be messed up anymore okay
so if you're thinking if you're thinking
of giving therapy a try better help is a
great option when you want to be a
better problem solver therapy can get
you there visit betterhealth.com
trash tuesday to get 10 off your first
month that's betterhelp.com
trash tuesday
you know what's weird are y'all watching
league of their own the no i haven't
watched it it's so great oh good it's so
wonderful
um but it does there's you know it's a
lot of lesbians playing baseball which i
didn't know
shocked me you thought it was a bigger
ball
this isn't gina davis
uh it's vagina davis
um but it's very it's you know very gay
very fun but at the same time you're
like holy [ __ ] this is like what it was
like back in like the you know 39 40
whenever whatever year it takes place
but it was like that they're like oh
well i got to marry a man i got to marry
a woman and then it was like
we go off into these like secret
clubs speakeasies like all that kind of
stuff it's wild and i and
my boyfriend and i were talking about it
last night i was like oh we would
totally be married to women like
back in the day i know you might be like
we gotta go to yeah we're i'm going to
go to jail if you went to jail for just
being gay i always feel like just as
like being like a loudspoken like kind
of free person like where i just kind of
like have my own rules and no boundaries
and stuff
i guess i have boundaries now but like
you know what i mean like i just do my
thing
that there's people that follow the
rules and they're like mad at you like
they get like you're mad at your freedom
like do you get that by closet from
closeted guys a lot where they're like
mad at you like you're having like a
great life and they're like but i'm
following the rules and you're getting
to have a great life well it's also
weird because like back when i started i
mean even like 2009 it still was very
like
you know being yourself yeah which is
mind-boggling yeah so now it's kind of
like loosened up in the past couple of
years but i wasn't getting work i wasn't
getting work because
i was gay i was not gay enough because
they wanted this like
you know like
yes queen she's giving it you know it's
like okay i can get that way but i'm not
that way yeah but i don't want to be
that old yeah it's like it's like i want
to just be a person i want to have a
beer with my friends
you know um
but
yeah now it's like wait
you know i'm getting these opportunities
and things are kind of moving along and
people are like well wait a minute yeah
you know put him back
what the hell is that let's go back to
2009.
right [ __ ] 2000 it is crazy how much
[ __ ] has changed in just that little
amount it is like it's hilarious like
how much like even jed apatow movies had
like [ __ ] and things like that like
just like crazy just like
really insane
and uh just not that long ago yeah and
then you think about it and it's like
yeah i don't know i always feel like
people like
just like being a girl that curses like
some people have a problem with like
just so i can't even imagine it's like
you're gay or whatever do you guys feel
like you ever have to like code switch
when you
like obviously when you're in at the
comedy store around comics there's just
like a free flow of just the worst
things you can say
you know to each other or whatever
there's like a freedom right you don't
have to weigh your thoughts or measure
your words it you just say what you say
yeah do you feel like
when you have to meet in-laws or people
or like regular people how much of it is
a struggle when you have to code switch
would
it is weird like because i was on
vacation for like oh yeah with my family
i was like it is not that i can still be
myself like i'm lucky i have like a good
family but it's like
yeah i'm not gonna be like hey [ __ ]
my boyfriend's parents like a couple
weeks ago if we went to
georgia
and they're just the sweetest the
sweetest
and his mom uh listen listens to my
podcast you know i'm like yeah but i'm
not like i don't try to make it a thing
but i was like on my best behavior you
know i grew up in the south as well so
it's like you know and they're very cool
with him and who he is so it's just like
you know i'm meeting like my boyfriend's
parents in the south
and um
we played cards against humanity
oh that's so fun that is the bridge that
is the bridge but i didn't realize i
don't know what's going on at the cards
against humanity factory like they are
just coming out with things yep
so this was like the everything bagel
package it was just a bagel with all the
everything bagel seasoning on it oh my
god well this looks in this looks
innocent right and so
playing the cards
i don't have anything like crazy dirty
his mom ends up winning
and then the dad who's like this you
know he's almost 70 sweet georgia man
he's like well
i don't know what to do with these two
cards i look at the two cards one of
them is
uh tongue [ __ ] my toes
and the other one is laying a
laying an egg out of my bird [ __ ]
and i'm like what why would they do that
and he would have won
sorry huh he would have won
he would have totally won my family is
like we're trash like my whole family's
like really like we're like garbage
trash mouth trash people like we just
are always like we're just like the
neighbors that are like you know what i
mean we're just the trash people
and so the sister-in-laws it was weird
you know when we were bringing them in
it was like how do we get the you can't
really ease into the letterman's because
it's all trash so
but like it was games like cards through
cards cards against humanity against
humanity and then there was one we did a
awkward family photos
and this is when my sister-in-law and i
really because my sister-in-law didn't
like me when we first met
i mean i'm sure she liked me fine but
she was my brother was like it was my
twin brother he was like
you know warned her like my sister's
like foul mouth or this was before i was
a comedian like before i got on tv my
behavior was absolutely insane once i
got on tv they're like
but like
so
when i met my sister-in-law they were
staying in my brother's room they were
like you know 22 or whatever and i just
said
when they went it when they went into
the room it better be a white wedding
[ __ ] like i was totally kidding yeah
but she like doesn't live with trash so
she didn't think you know so she like
took it personally or whatever took it
seriously and then eventually she opened
up stuff but we had one family vacation
we were playing awkward family photos
and i swear to god and so it was like
everyone was like there's a photo and
then you put the caption and then people
have to guess who wrote the which
caption so my mom is always saying the
most disgusting thing so you're
expecting my mom to be like fisting and
stuff like that
yes they're trash i'm telling you these
people are trash
and um i was raised by just like animals
absolute animals
and so there was one where was like like
a wedding dress when it was like
someone's fisting someone from behind
and when i realized it was my
sister-in-law
it was like she was in that was yeah so
now every vacation we have like the
cards against humanity moment so you
have like a kid version too that's
pretty wait have you guys heard uh
brother [ __ ] energy
it did not that's not me i know i was
gonna say i was like i think i've seen
it in your chair i've wait brother
[ __ ] energy
slip-ups not slip-ups i've i've had sex
with your shirt um thank thank you for
wearing that shirt i've had sex with um
my equivalent of a paul rudd i suppose
which is like brother yes yes yes so
anyways i'm known as the brother [ __ ]
of the of the crew of the podcast
esther's the lovable potato she's the
brother [ __ ] no but there's a real
thing called i think it's called brother
[ __ ] energy where sisters get overtly
jealous when their brother starts dating
someone oh
and they really kind of like put the
girl down say for instance or like i
think this is this is a tick tock yeah
this is it okay oh my god let me get my
ears wow how did that segue so perfectly
i'm excited about this kaleila you're a
genius
so this weekend i had the pleasure
of encountering my first brother [ __ ]
in the wild for those of you who don't
know let me explain a brother [ __ ] is
a girl who is close in age typically
with her sibling and is
acts in a strange way because she's
jealous and
deep down inside probably wants to sleep
with her brother
okay well
let me summarize it because it goes she
goes on on a long story about it but
basically she goes to a party and she
notices this girl across the room being
extremely rude to her
and she over her hears the girl saying
like why did you bring her she's so
mediocre
and she later finds out that that's not
just a jealous girl that's his sister
and i want to know if you've ever felt
that towards like a sibling ever where
you just feel like this need like that's
that's she's [ __ ] her brother right
no she's not i don't
you know as an older brother i've i've
you know i have one sister
you know and i've got three brothers and
we've just been very like
who's this guy yeah who's this guy he's
up to no good something's not right
and usually we're right right um but
yeah so i get that it could just be like
territorial it's like
family but i don't think it's i don't
think it's like a
oedipus complex you don't think it's a
lannister she was kind of boring atlanta
a lannister complex yeah she was
mediocre i'll say that yeah that girl no
no she was cute but i feel like with my
brother yeah you have your twin
no i my brother i never felt i always
liked my brother would like at all
confide in me or call me or need me or
what like it was always nice so i was
like i wanted to hear about his
girlfriends and stuff
but um
i would get jealous there was he had a
girlfriend in high school who
my mom took to the art museum and i was
like that's right mom can you take me to
the art museum i'm like the artist in
the family i was like
it was like that made me jealous i was
like what the [ __ ] is this [ __ ] but i
never was like no i never really had
that
but they were never like that with me
either they did when i broke up with my
um one of my boyfriends
they did all sigh they went oh
like
yeah or like and they were like i was
like why were you like worried about
when they were like every day we were
worried about you every day but they
never said
have you seen the the the two sets of
twins
that got married
uh uh it's like it's like two carlos
it's like goddammit now i gotta go to
work it's the two it's two twin sisters
two twin brothers and they got married
right
they had babies and those babies are not
only cousins but they're technically dna
siblings yeah this this thing it's so
bizarre they're dating yeah and they're
dating yeah they're the youngest babies
to i mean at this point they should just
like sister wives it that's what i'm
wondering i'm like how do you and
they're identical
i mean it's weird two twenty two twenty
two two two two two two two identical
twins do weird [ __ ] like they like
there's like
conventions for identical and i'm sure
they're all [ __ ] each other that's
what i thought and i didn't wanna think
that but you brought it up how upsetting
would it be to be the fat one though
that's what i always think about like oh
being the fat twin oh what a nightmare
you know i know a girl i mean this is
weird those are all twins yeah this is
strange that's all like it that's like a
twin convention wedding oh my god
yeah look at that it's weird this is
like an a24 film i don't want to look at
it anymore yeah that is so scary
yeah we just see esther hereditary too
that looks exactly like that but no but
i knew a girl who was estranged
[Music]
um i'm going to wait for this to get to
the correct um color but i knew a girl
who was estranged from her um twin
brother because he
molested her
so now i'm eating a banana so
narcissistic oh
right you're not if we gave you a
[ __ ] like banana break papaya that
would have been rafa oh yeah that would
have been weird i know i just have a
good podcast papaya
papaya break
um
yeah i mean
i guess if you were gonna be attracted
to someone
i'll have some high self-esteem oh by
the way so i ate so much food on this
trip my boyfriend's asia his mom's asian
you know so she would cook me i like
your boyfriend he's really sweet [ __ ]
incredible he's the most precious
but his mom vanessa she's the best
she like it's you know in her
cultures to just feed feed so she's
making me soup
she was like soup
all i want is for soup but i had so much
like rice porridge soup like i
gained yeah rice porridge super the best
i go back to my mom okay
i go to my mom orange soup wait i go mom
do i look like that
and she goes you know what i love about
you
she was i love you you have such a good
body image i went no no no not the
question i asked no no [ __ ] do i look
fatter
10 days later than when i came and i
came in in a low carb
working out every day and then i was
sick the entire time and i was chugging
nyquil and eating
rice soup do i look fatter and she's
like
and it's that body image that i like
about you i'm like you can't say it she
can't lie to me she can't do anything
she just can't give it to me well if
this makes you feel any better i think i
might have been the only person who came
out of covid 10 pounds heavier everyone
did we all did everyone did oh yeah no i
mean covet actually getting coveted oh
like i was mine was mine was wine weight
i know i
when people get sick they always somehow
look like frail and thin kind of sexy
i was the opposite it's almost like i go
into like a food panic and i just start
shoving things in my mouth that's what i
did this yeah oh i get it because i was
i'm so unhappy to go when you're like
i've been planning this family vacation
for so long to be sick the whole [ __ ]
time i was like depressed so i was just
like the only thing i do is eat things
that taste good but i was full and
vanessa was cooking me like we were
staying in their basement on an air
mattress by the way
i'm done with their mattresses oh you
shouldn't we could have gotta play i'm
just i was too sick to even get a hotel
like what were you sick with i had like
a [ __ ] [ __ ] up cold for like three
weeks yeah
you've never had worms no no randy had
worms when i first got them and i didn't
know if i could love them oh oh my god
you guys having worms is so underrated
it's actually quite you got really
skinny well no when you put this on your
dad she had no real pets as a kid i had
my pet jerry who was my worm
carrier worms was really underrated
you [ __ ] your worm too well he [ __ ]
me first let me tell you how it happened
so um did you put him back in
you wash them off the cycle never ends
it does not end i i pulled a worm out of
my butt when i was like eight years old
and nine and i remembered feeling just
the most wonderful tickle it's like when
you pull like a hair out when you pull a
hair out of your nose like you know the
hair accidentally gets up there and you
pull it out and it feels like it's
attached to your brain and your eyes
roll up i've never had that or when you
pull like an eye booger that's really
long across your eyes i've never had
that either these are asian things
you guys are just missing out on life
are we though have worms just in dry
worms i don't want to like i don't want
to
hear someone seeing me scratch my butt
up against the carpet like oh that's
cute
oh he's going viral again baby
barndale has worms no
okay so worms wasn't an american thing
oh yeah i didn't know anyone neither one
yeah i don't know long eye boogers
that's weird hair that makes your eyes
roll back
i don't necessarily think i lived in
atypical childhood i feel like i think
it's just youtube who's never had a
booger across the eye i don't know but
you live like you also were in like a
scary stories to tell in the dark novel
you were like you were like yeah i got
the zit once and i popped it and all
these baby spiders came out no no one
else i had tied my ribbon and my head
fell off
exactly
um how is your kalila like a month ago
did ketamine treatment how do you feel
i feel okay i think it helped with um
overall anxiety i will say that
um it really that's where i can see the
biggest difference
um more just detached i think which i'm
not really sure if i love because i've
always been someone who's like so close
to my emotions i thought you're going to
say to your ex boyfriends oh it's also
my ex-boyfriend
um
no no i wouldn't mean him i just meant i
was just teasing you because oh in
general my ex-boyfriend yeah i was like
let's call an ex-boyfriend i'm like
i don't have their numbers they always
pick up i did actually hit up one of my
ex-boyfriends recently which i never do
but i just he was one of those guys that
last time i saw him we used to always
like get like we'd get lunch or
something every few years we had like a
fine relationship nothing bad happened
or wasn't like too sad of a breakup or
anything but
last time i'd seen him he was in a dark
place so i was like let me just see if
he's with us still oh with the living
you know is he and i hit him up he's
like about to have a kid oh good oh wow
frozen embryos yeah like me and my
boyfriend and ours are all boys and
these are all girls i'm like we should
swap
trade sees yeah but i was i was like
this is like a best case scenario and
then i was like we're good i never
talked to you again
thank you to our sponsor native so
you've heard me talk about how much i
love native the thoughtful formulation
behind all of their products is
something that i have always loved
because they understand it's not just
what's on the inside that counts but
also on the outside that's why native is
releasing their deodorant that i know
and i love in new and improved plastic
free packaging lavender guys do you want
to take your pits to the spa
have a little lavender retreat
native is the answer baby native is
doing their part to help our earth with
their new 100 plastic free and
recyclable packaging when you buy
natives new plastic free recyclable
package deodorant you are saving 37
grams of plastic do you guys know that
the bacteria is actually farting and
that's what it is yes that's what i i
learned about that not long ago yeah
native is like gas x for your pits
okay natives also a proud partner of one
percent for the planet and are
committing one percent of their plastic
free deodorant sales to environmental
nonprofits as a one percenter i agree
and to remind you native is aluminum and
paraben free kills odor-causing bacteria
and has 24-hour odor protection to keep
you feeling fresh and smelling fresh you
can choose from 10 cents including their
classic coconut vanilla sensitive
formulas that are formulated without
baking soda and even unscented do you
want to smell my armpits carlos yeah
let's go
let me make sure
yeah no the worst they're hairy the
worst the better i think
oh yeah
made it
doesn't know they smell good yeah i'm
into that and they're sweaty but they
smell good yeah that's crazy listen we
can just pit out and not have to worry
about
stinking up the joint do you understand
what that's like
are you guys ready to try plastic free
deodorant go to
nativedl.com tuesday or use promo code
tuesday at checkout and get 20 off your
first order that's nativedo.com tuesday
or use promo code tuesday check out for
24 off your first order
uh didn't you have like a good panda
though did you meet you met your
boyfriend of the pandemic right no
after the pandemic yeah oh
yeah we met like last september it's
almost a year yeah
he just met his parents yeah it's new no
i'm not meeting anybody during the
pandemic are you kidding me i was so
good so good you had a good time i
wasn't like running to mykonos or [ __ ]
like that no like let's cover it's real
let's go to meek up no no was it doing
that no i wasn't on like like
cruise ships or anything like that no no
no no i was very it was crazy it was it
was a weird time it was so weird
remember we did did like like um
like the uh parking lot shows yeah and
did you do the window at the comedy
store
the the window i never did the window i
did my podcast my old podcast there like
we started it there which was the window
the window so they they open a window at
the comedy store they opened a window
and in the original room so it was
looking out into the front bar
but
legally they had to have it
it couldn't sync up time wise yeah
there were these weird rules right that
they were like finding these loopholes
to so it had to be on like a 30-second
delay
right so you're telling a joke you're
bombing you're eating you're bombing
you're telling a joke you're hitting the
punch line people are going
and then you're feeling like you're
bombing and they start laughing at you
yeah that's how it felt it was awful and
they set up that like weird like
makeshift patio with like the led
screens you can sit upset oh it's the
worst but the best the did you ever do
the magic castle shows with tammy jo i
did yeah that was like fun because joe
weirdly pulls out she
she gave like yeah she gave like
clappers to people so they were like
clap clap cause you're in your car it's
like a driving right right and you're
all this like weird i kept calling it
like a hope floats rascal flat set
because it was just like like this like
weird like texas barbecue stage
and like
they couldn't flash their lights and
they couldn't honk
so they would give you these little
clappers and they're like flashlight and
tignan
yeah and you're like this this is where
we're at this is where we're at i always
end up getting in fights with tammy jo
like we love each other but we always
get in fights and then i realize we're
both tops we're just both out oh yeah
full dominant silverback it's just we
i'm like why do we always fight it's
like we're all it's like because we're
just like
yeah did you live in a place where there
were a lot of gay guys when you were
young
uh no
wait no like what do you mean like did
you like in high school were there like
a lot of gay guys no no it was just it's
weird like my my high school was very
like
like can't hardly wait it was very like
that texas like varsity blues that
really was a fun movie everyone got
along it was just the weirdest thing
like i went to a private school and
that's where a lot of gay guys came from
so i came from private school to a to a
public school
um my second semester sophomore year and
by like
my senior in high school i was
homecoming king like i went in there and
was just like
yeah did you turn out
no no but i mean like but you're a guy
yeah i mean because it wasn't like
talked about yeah yeah it was weird i
didn't have like like you were just kind
of like okay you have your boyfriend you
have your girlfriend that was it like
who are you dating i was dating like the
captain of the dance team i was dating
like the homecoming queen at one point
like but it was like friendly but like
we kind of also messed around but it
wasn't like
i feel like you lived in glee
that's crazy like glee it just feels
like glee it was very like
every every every i mean i don't know in
my i could be completely wrong like
there could have been a student who was
just like it [ __ ] sucks yeah but like
everybody that all the different cliques
and groups we all kind of like really
got along too i like that my house was
insane but there was a friend of mine
well
wasn't a friend of mine at the time but
he was like one of like the big like
football players and
he like came out and was like oh yeah
you know i'm gay and i'm like
and he came out yeah i was like you you
like made fun of me in high school and
stuff and he's like yeah i was just like
really insecure with myself he's like
you know but we would all like jerk off
in the locker room like after practice
and stuff and i was like
and
and you and you guys didn't call me yeah
you're like i would have loved to have
been there
i was
that's that is crazy i think there's so
much gay [ __ ] going on at all times
always if there's a locker room i know
like i i can't ima i can't think of one
person who isn't
somewhat fluid like
i just it's hard to find now right like
if we were to
give ourselves like permission like true
permission
i think we'd all be okay with like
[ __ ] everyone mm-hmm
like but that's just i feel like it's
getting more totally loose now yeah
totally
not not annie but like actually i'm
getting tighter i'm getting tighter i'm
getting tighter like people with their
sexuality is getting more i don't know
looser because one of my favorite things
is i love objectifying men
i love it i do too
well as a man doing it
it's so like i i encourage women you
like to do it to straight guys oh for
sure i do it on stage like some guy the
other night was like
i said where are you from and he was
like oh i don't even remember where he's
from but i i said oh
that's great and i go oh you're from the
city and he goes yes sir and i was like
did you just yesterday and i go okay
daddy and he was just like oh
and i love i love it yeah and honestly
everybody should feel what that's like
that's my favorite thing and just
because it's like both of you like
you know you get like head on the street
and you're like oh thank you no no okay
i feel like every i think every comedian
could have like a pop star
associated with them what am i
you're like
uh
wait hold on i've got this i've got this
i've got this i've got this
let me look pop story
you're like trash no you're like a tuna
can yeah
bonnie rate no you are you are betty
rates well they're like i would say
you're cut i mean you're very like rock
star i would say i would say like avril
lavigne
i i
i like
a little harder i think a lot more like
true rock and roll like like whole like
yes
i love
that [ __ ]
trash garbage you found the garbage
there you go my favorite album lived
through this the best celebrity skins
so good i do wake up in my makeup
yeah um i feel like i mean you didn't
pick like hot ones but it's okay she is
hot to me yeah she esther is like
esther is is modest mouse a girl
i think esther's probably like a jojo
siwa or like she's um
she's dave roll
she is gay girl have you ever seen them
in the same room at the same time me
neither dave girl and esther i think
esther would probably be like
she wants to be lady gaga so bad yeah
no she doesn't want to be lady gaga she
wants to be like
what does esther want to be oh my god
she's billy island she's billy eilish
she's really eyelash she's like a baby
yeah i was gonna say for you and this
would really like make esther sad but a
little bit of lana del rey as well it's
kind of like just that rebel like kind
of
sad sad girl eating cheese yeah but also
i like cheesecake i like sexy sexy
wash it down with a pepsi cola yeah but
motorcycles you know what i mean i would
like to be lady gaga but that's okay i
don't think there is a lady gaga
i'm morphing i'll work on it
you just she's a morph she's a mormon
coat cans in your hair she's the more
cigarette i know this is the the beef
there i look like leona you just show up
in the roast beef dress we're like annie
god jesus christ danny
i look like who do i look like it's like
rotting meat who do i look like which
pop star am i it's the or on a tuesday
what are you doing let's do more
um i think who would be um
whitney would be
uh
oh my god this is avril lavigne
whitney's like
hang on hang on
oh wait you're kind of a kesha yes there
it is right yes you're kesha take kesha
i'll take kesha i'll take all of them
that you gave me i like kesha i would
say would be a uh
who is whitney whitney would be
gwen stefani's like religious
yeah she said she's always been kind of
a good girl i think whitney would be
britney
oh my god
[Music]
i had a friend
who she tried to throw me a surprise
party at whitney's house like she tried
to get herself like
into what like
why would that happen
in the group like she was like i'm gonna
throw a surprise party for you like she
told you know obviously todd was like
and she's like so she's trying to get
todd to like set it up at whitney's
house so that she would then bring all
these people i don't like
into my famous friends mansions yep
i mean that's what was weird i remember
walking at the store
with with ex-boyfriend
and he would be like justin take a
picture of me and natasha and i'm like i
don't what no these are my peers like
we're not panning out over oh my god and
my boyfriend my boyfriend now like his
one of his like she was performing in la
jolla and i was like i'll go check out
my friend
i didn't even get to talk to him yeah i
know yeah and he took his brother to go
see annie and i was like i was like how
was she he was like
she had really strong brother [ __ ]
energy and i was like yeah
i was so jealous i consider you a
brother i was like you're a little
mediocre
wow wow
i didn't like him he's really one sister
did you know that i have four kids you
know what i do have a lot of girlfriends
though at the in in comedy which i
really love i have a lot of good girls i
love the girls in comedy i think there's
like a lot of really good i've learned
to distance myself from some of them but
the ones that i have i'm like
distance yourself from them yeah when
you see them every once in a while you
go i can [ __ ] appreciate that [ __ ]
now mm-hmm you don't get to hang out
with them all the time i've had like
falling outs of female comedians and
stuff yeah but i'm like
there's no one that
it's gonna ruin my day oh right i mean
you just talk you mean you mean they're
tolerable yeah you can just kind of be
like okay well you enough years happened
there was one girl in new york
oh she was such a stupid [ __ ] we used
to do girl code together i won't say her
name but she sucks and i don't [ __ ]
care if she finds out
she there were so many like great girls
on the show there was this one girl that
i used to open mics with her she had
blocked me on facebook at one point just
like weird she was just so mad and she
would be like you never stay
for my set at open mics i'm like i don't
even know your name
i don't know who you are that sounds
like she might have been into you
it was like she was so mad at me that it
was she's just like a narcissist that's
something a girl would tell her
boyfriend but she was like one of those
people that you like
she's one of those people like she was
staying at my friend's house and my
friend and her
uh boyfriend were like dead asleep and
she couldn't find her jacket and she
just like woke them up screaming like
where's my she's one of those people
where it's like her day yeah and it
doesn't matter what's happening with
anyone else it's like her day so she was
like that so i think she just was like
oh why wouldn't you stay for mice i'm
like i didn't even know you were going
out i don't know who's in the room when
i'm doing an open mic but she i saw her
once we were going into the same hotel
and i was like upset about something i
like left my ipad on the
the plane or something so i was on the
phone with my dad and i was like upset
and she looked back and like smirked at
me
and i just went
you know what we're done i went you know
what we're [ __ ] done i've done this
for seven years i've tried with you you
[ __ ] suck i try to give you the
benefit of the doubt exactly i always
try because you're taking pleasure and
me being upset you [ __ ] suck you're
one of the worst people i've ever met
just don't [ __ ] ever talk to me again
we're just not even going to play this
game anymore and then you think after
someone calls you like the worst person
in the world you would act like nice and
cool yeah we went up to
we were both getting our hotel rooms
so we go up to like the we're next to
each other they get me like i'm on like
the ninth floor or something and the
elevators were actually really slow and
i was like that sucks to be that high
but who cares so i'm just like being
nice having fun with the person getting
my key or whatever she the person goes
to her uh your room's on the second
floor she goes no it's not
and they go
sorry that's where she was i'm not it'll
wake me up i'm not gonna be able to be
that close to the street or whatever and
she's like i need a dip i need a
different floor like this is the only
room we have available yeah and um she
starts screaming at them it's like this
person's just at work you [ __ ] [ __ ]
but i'm here i could have traded with
her
but i wasn't gonna trade and i just went
see look at you the worst person i've
ever [ __ ] met and i just never talked
to her actually the last time i saw her
was my friend was my friend's husband
was playing on like a softball team
and those random like there's just
random people in l.a playing softball
and i went to one of the games and i
just saw a girl punch a dog god and i
and then i looked and it was her and i
went of course
it was her i go of course you punch a
[ __ ] dog you wouldn't even know who
she was
i need to know it's probably best
because i would just anyway that's our
like on that uh punching dog note
this is jake well sorry
this is three weeks a day quote guys had
nothing but rice all week rice soup i'm
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
lugow baby here i am lugao is what we
call our rice porridge but also when
your brain is lugo oh i'm lugo that's
perfect yeah why do you got a little
girl
la luga ray that's your pop star and
then i pull i pull a worm out of my ass
i call my fans the ass worms you guys
thank you so much for tuning in today
thank you again justin for being here of
course spiral hip please oh my god
he ruined j.lo
no i didn't he ruined her
on her wedding month no less
the funny thing was real quick she like
was more pissed off about whoever
recorded her
singing at the wedding because they all
signed nda's then like you know whatever
happened she's like dying at her own
wedding oh yeah
she's like this one goes out to my
husband no
and he was like friend on tv
okay i there's this other one that i it
was so [ __ ] cringe but as she's
walking down the aisle she's singing not
jlo but another person and then i'm like
probably got to stop
yeah this is that i'd be mortified if i
was the husband it's just like princess
diana gifting prince charles like a
video of her like um dancing no is that
what happened yes did you not watch the
crown
no i didn't watch the crown i love the
crowd i mean i love princess diana she
can do no wrong but she was that type of
person she's like charles is gonna love
this and it's just a video of her like
being a ballerina did you see the new
game of thrones oh not yet i've i'm
bobby and i i'm 20 minutes in and i fell
asleep but not because i wasn't
interested the first one's good the
second one i fell asleep but todd keeps
going
todd's never watched it he's like he's
like oh the targaryens are are they
um barbarians this is so contrarian he's
like just makes fun of it he like hates
it so much wow you should question your
life with him he's the best
he's bored with everything are the
targaryens barbarians are they're
barbarians or contrarian
no they're
they are uh incestuarians
i know like should i marry or not maddie
that is so boring so boring the second
one though yeah
but they have to have the boring ones
to get to the goat the next one's like
full battle right it will be it has a
full battle with dragons they go after
the crab feeder which is also esther's
uh
yeah
i just [ __ ] on esther i love her to
death i just love her we love esther we
only show that esther that's like how
you should that's her love language is
to just be bullied she's just she's just
like santino trash i'd
so it's like we have to it is like we
see all this [ __ ] on us too it is
punching down though she is about two
feet tall but we love our little
munchies we miss her too and we'll see
you guys next week bye guys
[Music]